[Applause]
after two weeks of major protests on the
streets of Iran they have now shifted to
universities as the new Academic Year
starts
hundreds of people have been arrested
during unrest since the death in police
custody of 22 year old Masai amini in
mid-september
at Sheriff University of Technology in
Tehran dozens of students were detained
after fighting with the security forces
at other top universities in the
country's largest cities students held
rallies despite Security Forces trying
to disperse them
the supreme leader accuses foreign
powers of engineering the Andres to
destabilize the country
again
I openly state that the recent riots and
unrest in Iran are schemes designed by
the U.S the usurping fake Zionist regime
their mercenaries and for some
treasonous Iranians abroad who helped
them these rights have been planned if
the death of this young girl didn't
happen they would have found another
pretext to create chaos in the country
and harm the country's security
that was heartbreaking for him too but
he criticized people's reactions before
the result of any official investigation
Iran Supreme
lead and Parliament speaker have also
announced that a final report on Masa I
mean is that will be released soon and
anyone found responsible will be held
accountable but many people are already
questioning its credibility Tehran